le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
l'insertion professionnelle n'est pas
toujours facile pour les jeunes chefs de
file de l'action sociale le département
développe plusieurs dispositifs en
faveur de ce public souvent motivées
mais parfois démunis devant le monde du
travail le plan 4000 jeunes parrainés a
pour but d'aider ces personnes à devenir
acteurs de leur développement en les
accompagnant dans leurs projets
gwenaëlle a 25 ans cette ancienne mère
au foyer gère aujourd'hui son propre
magasin
[Musique]
un
garçon s'appelle macarez quotidien magar
est ce parce que c'est mon dîner gâté le
mélange de marez ma gâchis tibia parce
qu'il est multi bien depuis ce qui
touche à la mode
du coup là celui là mais comme
d'habitude par là
gwenaëlle a ouvert sa boutique il y à un
mois à la base du projet le rêve de son
petit garçon nous avons vraiment
tout le temps super bien habiter tout
pourquoi pas ouvrir un magasin
plus de sous
[Musique]
gwenaëlle a arrêté l'école en 4e après
la naissance de ses deux enfants elle
devient mère au foyer et vit du rsa à 25
ans elle n'a jamais travaillé suivant
les conseils de son fils et malgré son
manque d'expérience elle décide de se
lancer souvent en fait on dit des
personnes qui n'ont pas fait d'études
valent rien et ben moi aujourd'hui je
peux prouver on en sait que c'est un
c'est pas le temps tout est possible oui
mais il suffit juste d'avoir la volonté
et de pas baisser les bras dans sa
boutique gwenaëlle vend toutes sortes de
produits de beauté pour femmes du
maillot de bain au parfum en passant par
les bijoux elle a même lancé sa propre
collection c'est ma première création
[Musique]
pour réaliser son projet la jeune maman
a pu bénéficier du plan 4000 jeunes
parrainé ce dispositif départemental
vise à accompagner un public fragilisé
pour qu'il devienne acteur de son
développement personnel qu'on s'adresse
surtout à des jeunes qui sont en dehors
du système de la scolarité pour voir
avec leur projet de vie en tant que
département nous allons les accompagner
pour qu' ils soient
opérationnels et qu'il soit ils arrivent
à leur but final c'est à dire pouvoir
peut-être travailler peut-être vous
épanouir dans un club de sport peut-être
avoir un vêtement nécessaire pour
accéder à votre
informations ou bien les moyens
nécessaires en tout cas pour que vous
réalisez votre projet de vie c'est très
important
s'adapter au parcours de vie de chacun
c'est la volonté du département pour
soutenir l'insertion professionnelle des
jeunes aujourd'hui vous avez deux jeunes
sur trois ans 30 16 25 ans qu'on
travaille pas à partir de là le
département de l'art de la réunion
entrepris un programme qui est innovant
qui consiste à aider directement les
jeunes situation on va créer les
conditions qui vont conduire vers une
ascension profession et c'est du sur
mesure afin de vous raccrochez un projet
denis a créé votre propre travail bref
pas s'insérer
parmi les mesures adaptées du dispositif
le nouveau pack jeune citoyen est
l'outil financier qui a permis à
gwenaëlle d'acquérir ces articles elle a
aussi bénéficié du système de parrainage
de ce programme
[Musique]
mirella est la marraine de cette
aventure
pendant un an et demi elle a suivi et
conseillé la jeune chef d'entreprise je
n'ai vraiment accompagner tout ce qui
était montage demande de financement
ensuite je vais accompagner aussi à
concrétiser un petit peu son projet de
création elle venait me voir et me
disais voilà je ne peux plus comment je
vais faire ce que tu peux me conseiller
je dis bah écoute il faut pas s'arrêter
là il faut continuer persévérer puis tu
veras aboutira aussi fait maintenant de
ma création wavrin oasis suis
aujourd'hui wind and finalise sa
première collection elle envisage
l'avenir avec espoir espère ouvrir un
jour un deuxième magasin
[Musique]
le plan 4000 jeunes paris mais a pour
objectif de remobiliser le jeune de
l'insérer socialement de l'accompagner
dans sa professionnalisation
il propose un accompagnement par un
professionnel référent et par un parrain
ou une marraine le jeune peut aussi
bénéficier d'une aide financière adaptée
à son projet pouvant aller jusqu'à 4000
euros via le nouveau pack jeune citoyen
les jeunes pourront prétendre à ce
dispositif doivent être âgés de 16 à 25
ans ils sont exclus du système scolaire
et sont en recherche d'insertion sociale
ou professionnelle
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
appeler le numéro vert 0 800 1 801 000
ou vous rapprocher de la maison
départementale la plus proche de chez
vous
[Musique]
m